what do imaginary dogs monsters from
another dimension and a live
decapitation have in common they're all
from projects starring these former lord
of the rings stars here's what the lord
of the rings looks like now
and
now the journey doesn't end here since
the lord of the rings days elijah wood
has been an instantly recognizable star
and has had a delightfully eclectic
resume doing everything from high
profile films to animated voiceover
roles to quirky television series wood
provided the voices for mumble in
dreamworks's family-friendly happy feet
and worked in cartoon network's spooky
over the garden wall he starred in the
series dirk gently's holistic detective
agency and wilfred and has appeared in
films such as eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind sin city and i don't feel
at home in this world anymore each other
makes me
so furious
kevin stop it
most recently wood has lent his voice
acting talents to the disney channel
animated series star wars resistance and
cartoon network's summer camp island but
has also stayed busy in live action
roles starring income to daddy in 2019
and no man of god in 2021 perhaps best
known for his role as frodo's right-hand
man samwise gamgee actor sean astin has
changed a lot since portraying the loyal
and tender-hearted hobbit prior to the
lord of the rings aston was known for
playing mikey walsh in the classic
children's adventure film the goonies
and as the title character in famous
notre dame football walk-on story rudy
since the lord of the rings though aston
hasn't returned to the film spotlight
appearing only in smaller supporting
roles in movies like the adam sandler
comedy's 50 first dates and click
instead aston has done a lot of
voice-over work for various animated
series lending his vocal talents to
everything from teenage mutant ninja
turtles to captain underpants aston has
also guest start on a wide variety of
television series including law and
order 24 and brooklyn 99 and he's been
part of the cast of various live action
miniseries he played jim kent on the fx
series the strain sunny grice on hbo's
perry mason and most notably bob newby
in netflix's mega hit series stranger
things aston also starred in the netflix
original sitcom no good nick which ran
for two seasons
undoubtedly the most decorated of all
the lord of the rings cast members sir
ian mckellen only looks all the more
wiser than when he played legendary
wizard gandalf the white and previously
gandalf the grey the knighted actor has
more awards than you can shake a
wizard's staff at mckellen won a golden
globe award for his role in the made for
tv movie rasputin
he's also won two saturn awards in annie
award an honorary golden berlin bear two
british independent film awards two
critics choice awards two screen actors
guilds awards and the list only goes on
from there he is an accomplished stage
actor in addition to one of the big
screen's biggest stars with the lord of
the rings merely being another
accomplishment to add to his already
extensive resume of fine films here the
hammer stroke will fall hardest mcallen
reprised his role as gandalf in the
hobbit trilogy of films and has also had
an impressive run as magneto in fox's
x-men films more recently he has starred
in the national theater live production
of king lear in 2018 as gus the theater
cat in the movie musical cats and as a
con artist opposite dame helen mirren in
the 2019 film the good liar
although boromir will always be known as
the one member of the fellowship who
tried to take the ring from frodo sean
bean imbued the character with warmth
and nobility
please
his loss at the end of the fellowship of
the ring still feels tragic despite his
earlier actions following the lord of
the rings bean went on to appear in
numerous films including troy national
treasure and percy jackson and the
olympians the lightning thief in 2011
the actor took on what would become his
most notable role as leading man ned
stark on the first season of game of
thrones the hit tv adaptation of george
rr martin's popular a song of ice and
fire book series
however spoiler alert he gets his head
lopped off in the penultimate episode of
the debut season
although playing characters who meet
tragic ends is nothing new for bean as
the actor is notorious for being killed
off in what seems like every role he's
ever played
since game of thrones bean has continued
to appear in significant roles in films
such as jupiter ascending and the
martian although his work has taken a
turn toward television in more recent
years after starring in the bbc series
broken in 2017 bean went on to appear in
series such as the frankenstein
chronicles world on fire and snow
piercer
a household name today orlando bloom is
no longer the immortal babyfaced alvin
bowman we first met in the lord of the
rings trilogy despite efforts to make
him appear that way in the hobbit films
for a while following the lord of the
rings bloom continued to gravitate
toward grand scale combat heavy
blockbusters he starred in the first
three films in the pirates of the
caribbean series co-starred alongside
brad pitt and eric banner in troy and
led the historical epic kingdom of
heaven in recent years though bloom has
drifted toward more tonally diverse
projects starring in the disturbing
trauma drama retaliation in 2017 and the
gritty war film the outpost in 2020
bloom has also made the jump to
television starring in amazon's
victorian fantasy series carnival row
and voicing prince harry in hbo's
animated series the prince and he is in
the reality bending 2021 time travel
drama needle in a time stack in which he
plays a romantic rival to leslie odom
jr's temporally challenged protagonist
he's known for playing the more serious
of the two hobbits who decided to tag
along with the fellowship despite not
being invited dominic monahan the actor
behind maria doc brandy buck isn't quite
the pipeweed smoking halfling we
remember from the lord of the rings
films
following the lord of the rings monahan
went on to play charlie pace in the
first three seasons of abc's juggernaut
series lost a character that possibly
rivaled even mary in notability
the english actor also played chris
bradley in x-men origins wolverine along
with a number of other film roles that
are much less well known
after his time on lost monahan had
regular roles on numerous television
series including flash forward 100 code
and quantum break monahan also spent
several years hosting wild things with
dominic monaghan a wildlife documentary
series nominated for numerous awards
in recent years monahan has continued to
act appearing in a small role in star
wars episode 9 the rise of skywalker
along with several smaller projects he
also has appeared on numerous podcasts
and still hosts one along with the lord
of the rings co-star billy boyd called
the friendship onion
you'd be forgiven for not being able to
name another film featuring billy boyd
the actor behind the lord of the rings
peregrine pippen tuke no doubt it would
be due to not recognizing the middle
aged actor because he always manages to
look younger than he really is much like
a hobbit boyd's biggest role by far was
playing the most confused pipeweed
toking hobbit in the fellowship although
boyd continued to act following the lord
of the rings his roles have not been
nearly as memorable his most notable
part was playing barrett bondin in the
russell cross the epic master in
commander the far side of the world but
don't be too sad for boyd since his true
passion is music the famous hobbit is
the front man for a band called bee cake
playing guitar and providing vocals boyd
also wrote and performed the end credits
theme for the hobbit the battle of the
five armies further lending his
influence to middle earth and providing
trivia material for die-hard hobbit fans
in recent years boyd has guest starred
on a number of television shows
including doom patrol grey's anatomy and
a short arc on
outlander you'd probably no longer
recognize viggo mortensen as the
long-haired ranger who launched himself
into a battle with a group of ring race
on weathertop wielding a sword and a
flaming torch
now mortensen is older and grayer but
still knows how to command the screen
before the lord of the rings mortenson
had already come into his own as an
actor spending the 90s acting in a
number of notable films including gi
jane a perfect murder and a walk on the
moon nevertheless peter jackson's
award-winning trilogy cemented the
danish american actor's place in the
film industry
exhausting being me mortensen later
acted in david cronenberg films a
history of violence and eastern promises
the latter earning him an academy award
nomination for best actor working well
together the director and actor teamed
up again for 2011's a dangerous method
which landed mortensen a golden globe
nomination for best supporting actor
then in 2018 mortensen starred alongside
mahershala ali in green book which won
an academy award for best pitcher
mortensen continues to be a highly in
demand actor with numerous major
upcoming projects including ron howard's
13 lives and another collaboration with
david cronenberg crimes of the future
before playing gimli the ax-wielding
dwarf who refuses to be tossed except
when there's no other choice john reese
davies was probably best known as salah
the affable arab in the indiana jones
films
since the lord of the rings however rhys
davies has appeared in dozens of films
video games and tv series including both
live action and voice over rolls do you
know who i am prior to the lord of the
rings rhys davies was already a highly
accomplished television actor with roles
in series such as the untouchables
sliders star trek voyager and the living
daylights
he continued to pursue all types of
acting after the lord of the rings
making appearances on dozens of shows
including psych the shannara chronicles
and wizards
rhys davies has also regularly appeared
in films although none as big as the
lord of the rings
most recently the definitely not
dwarvish actor standing at slightly
above average six feet one inch has
worked on a number of smaller films
including kingslayer and bad cupid
after getting her start in film starring
in music videos for her father's band
aerosmith liv tyler made a name for
herself in the 90s in lighthearted films
that thing you do and empire records
she also starred in quieter dramas such
as stealing beauty and inventing the
abbotts before moving on to play bruce
willis daughter in michael bay's
cataclysmic blockbuster armageddon so it
came as a surprise to many when she was
cast as arwen the immortal daughter of
the elf lord elrond and the love
interest of aragorn in the lord of the
rings
but tyler seized the role and made it
her own fitting right in among the rest
of the cast and story despite arwen
being a much smaller part of the books
following the lord of the rings tyler
was one of the first actors to be
recruited into the marvel cinematic
universe with her role as betty ross in
the incredible hulk although
unfortunately for her that film tends to
be intentionally omitted from the mcu
canon by most fans and tyler hasn't been
seen in the superhero franchise since
after starring in a few more films tyler
pivoted to television starring as meg
abbott in hbo's the leftovers and later
as lady isabella fits william in the
hulu period drama harlots most recently
tyler appeared opposite brad pitt in the
sci-fi drama at astra and in a
10-episode arc on the firefighting
series 9-1-1 lone star
hugo weaving has a knack for playing
ageless characters starring as the
sentient computer program agent smith in
the matrix before taking on the role of
elrond and the lord of the rings
however the two could not have been more
different with smith determined to
destroy neo and his human resistance
while elrond worked to save the world of
men from sauron and the power of the one
ring after starring in the lord of the
rings weaving would reprise his role as
smith in the matrix sequels and also as
elrond in the hobbit films but his
iconic roles wouldn't end there he also
played v in v for vendetta red skull and
captain america the first avenger and
voiced megatron in the transformers
films weaving's other film roles include
cloud atlas hacksaw ridge and the peter
jackson helmed mortal engines
most recently weaving appeared in the
australian streaming series love me and
as dr bergman and the sci-fi thriller
expired for many actors the lord of the
rings would be the obvious high point of
their career however the role as the
elven queen galadriel in the lord of the
rings is a mere side note in kate
blanchett's impressive career
the actor owns enough academy awards
british academy awards golden globe
awards and other awards to fill a house
she is the first performer to win an
oscar for portraying another
oscar-winning performer thanks to her
role as katherine hepburn in the aviator
there we both are
with such accolades it's clear that
blanchett's role on film have been
extensive and noteworthy her
oscar-nominated roles also include notes
on a scandal i'm not there elizabeth the
golden age blue jasmine and carol but
her memorable performances go far beyond
that in addition to reprising her role
as galadriel in all three films of the
hobbit trilogy blanchett has wowed
audiences in the curious case of
benjamin button thor ragnarok ocean's 8
and nightmare alley in 2020 she starred
in the fx miniseries mrs america and as
part of the ensemble cast of netflix's
mini series stateless blanchett
currently has numerous other features in
tv miniseries in the works and if the
past is any indication we're sure she
has many more awards in her future as
well david wayneum the actor known in
the lord of the rings universe as
faramir has been busy since his days of
fighting for gondor and the world of men
wenham broke through into the upper tier
of actors by starring as diver dan in
abc's sea change
it was a highly successful television
series that helped land the actor an
important role in the second and third
installment of the lord of the rings
trilogy after middle earth was saved
waynum moved on to a pair of supporting
roles alongside hugh jackman and gerard
butler
he played friar carl and van helsing and
delios the narrator and warrior and
stylistic persian slaying epic 300 in
2009 wenham went back to the stage
playing the title character in jerry
springer the opera which ran for six
sold out days at the sydney opera house
the following year he portrayed
melbourne lawyer andrew fraser's long
fall from the top in the australian
television series killing time most
recently wenham has had a series of
small screen roles including harold
meacham in iron fist al parker in top of
the lake jagozak in romper stomper and
bryce galice in les norton in between
wenham has still managed to squeeze in
some film roles lending his voice to the
peter rabbit films and appearing in
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales he can next be spotted as hank
snow in the bas lerman biopic elvis
as denethor the merciless steward of
gondor john noble certainly didn't do
much to endear himself to fans as his
character sent his only living son on a
pointless suicide mission he then
attempted to finish the job by burning
him alive denethor died horribly first
catching fire on the pyre meant for his
son then throwing himself from the
highest point of osgiliath in the lord
of the rings the return of the king
noble's next major role would prove to
be far more ingratiating as lovable
scientist walter bishop in the hit
sci-fi series fringe
noble starred on the series for 100
episodes between 2008 and 2013 arguably
cementing that character in pop culture
even over denathore following the end of
fringe noble went on to appear in a
number of television series including
sleepy hollow elementary and dc's
legends of tomorrow noble also still
occasionally appears in films with one
of his most recent roles being in
silencio currently noble voices the
diviner on the animated paramount plus
series star trek prodigy
after galloping into the lord of the
rings films as eomer one of the fearless
writers of rohan carl urban went on to
have an impressive career following the
conclusion of the trilogy he starred in
action-packed films such as the bourne
supremacy the chronicles of riddick and
doom urban's next big break came in 2009
when he starred alongside chris pine and
zachary quinto as leonard bones mccoy
and jj abrams star trek reboot urban's
impressive deforest kelly impersonation
won him the favor of star trek fans
worldwide he would go on to reprise the
role in two sequels with another on the
way
you'll love it urban also entered the
marvel cinematic universe as scourge in
thor ragnarok and appeared in a number
of films and television series in
between giant blockbusters including a
starring role in the short-lived sci-fi
series almost human in 2019 he began
playing the role of billy butcher on
amazon's popular superhero series the
boys with multiple major franchises and
a super successful tv series under his
belt it's safe to say that carl urban
has been doing pretty well for himself
post the lord of the rings
australian actress miranda otto already
had an impressive resume prior to the
lord of the rings appearing in numerous
films and television series before
taking on the role of the fierce
shieldmaiden eowyn first introduced in
the two towers eowyn was the sister of
eomer and the niece of king theoden of
rohan who was not content to hide from
battle along with the other women and
children she instead disguised herself
as a man in order to fight
eowyn was the only character in the
films to successfully take down a
ringwraith iconically lopping the head
off of a fel beast before killing the
witch king of angmar during the battle
of pelanor fields
after the lord of the rings otto
continued to work regularly in both
television and film with recurring roles
in shows including homeland and 24
legacy and a regular role on netflix's
chilling adventures of sabrina next up
otto can be seen in the upcoming modern
fantasy the portable door she will also
appear in all the colors of the dark a
tense immigration drama in which otto
will star alongside noah wiley
several years after playing the captain
of the doomed ship in titanic bernard
hill would go on to portray a much more
heroic leader as king theodin of rohan
in the lord of the rings films
theodin was first introduced as a frail
old man in the two towers but after
breaking the dark enchantment that had
been cast over him gandalf restored
theodin to health and vitality theodin
went on to lead the armies of rohan to
victory against the orcs of eisenguard
despite overwhelming odds but ultimately
was killed by the witch king of angmar
during the battle of pelonar fields
bernard hill had a long and impressive
acting career prior to the lord of the
rings and continued to work regularly
afterward he appeared in dozens of films
and television shows and earned an emmy
nomination for his portrayal of david
blunkett in the television movie a very
social secretary however in recent years
hill seems to have taken some time off
with his last significant role being as
the narrator of an episode of the tv
docu-series horizon in 2016.
still hill does appear to have some
projects in the hopper with several
films in various stages of production
buried under piles of greasy black hair
and without eyebrows you may not have
recognized brad dora from his roles in
significant films such as one flew over
the cuckoo's nest and 1984's dune he
appeared as the sniveling grima worm
tongue in the lord of the rings
a not so secret double agent who was
loyal to saruman while ostensibly
serving king theoden wormtongue
manipulated rohan's king to do the white
wizards bidding that is until saruman's
enchantment was broken by gandalf and
worm tongue was exiled worm tongue later
betrayed saruman 2 stabbing him in the
back literally before being shot with
arrows and killed doroth has provided
the voice of chucky the killer doll
throughout the child's play franchise
and continued to do so after the lord of
the rings i don't believe it i just
don't believe it he also appeared as
sheriff lee brackett in rob zombie's
2007 halloween remake and its sequel
doroth didn't just make horror movies
though he's appeared in numerous films
as well as guest starred on a number of
television shows including once upon a
time and agents of shield currently
doroth is still voicing chucky in the
sci-fi original series chucky and has
roles in several films still in
production
new zealand actor greg parker played
haldir in the first two lord of the
rings films the lothlorian elf who first
greeted the fellowship upon their entry
into the mystical woods
he later showed up to help support the
men of rohan in their stand against the
forces of isengard at helm's deep
tragically despite the immortality of
the elves haldir was slain during the
battle of helm's deep driving home for
both aragorn and the audience just how
high the cost of the fighting was
prior to the lord of the rings parker
was mostly known for playing guy warner
in the new zealand soap opera shortland
street
the role is one he reprised again in
2007 for the show's 15th anniversary and
continued to play through 2008. parker
also appeared in a number of other
television shows and recurring or main
roles including legend of the seeker
spartacus reign and charmed most
recently parker appeared in a recurring
role in the free form show good trouble
playing pompous artist yuri elwyn
in a role that was mostly performed
through motion capture andy circus
didn't have a lot of screen time in the
lord of the rings however he still came
out of the experience as a household
name thanks to his brilliant portrayal
of the tragic and singularly focused
golem thanks to his nuanced and emotive
motion capture and voice performance
circus would go on to make a name for
himself as the go-to motion capture
performer in hollywood he later brought
to life characters such as the titular
ape and king kong supreme leader snoke
and star wars and caesar in the planet
of the apes films
but circus also continued to act on
screen as well appearing in a number of
well-received and highly publicized
films such as 13 going on 30 the
prestige and black panther along with
smaller titles that are less well known
circus also stepped behind the lens to
direct as a second unit director for the
hobbit trilogy which also saw him
reprise his role as gollum he went on to
direct several other feature films as
well including the recent dark superhero
flick venom let there be carnage
recently circus continues to dip his
toes into as many lucrative franchises
as possible he had his recent role as
alfred in the batman and has several
projects including film sequels original
films and a video game voiceover role
currently in the works
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]